خبر جيد لكوكب الارض للبيئه والمناخ
والبشر القنبله السكانيه تتوقع حدوثها في
منتصف القرن انتظارها قد لا تنفجر دراسه
نشرتها صحيفه الجارديان من المحتمل ان يصل
عدد السكان الى الذروه في وقت اقرب واقل
مما كان متوقعا في السابق فوفقا لاتجاهات
الحاليه تتوقع دراسا عدد سكان العالم سيصل
الى ثمانيه مليارات و800 مليون نسمه قبل
منتصف القرن ثم ينخفض بسرعه الدراسه توجدت
ان الذروه يمكن ان تاتي في وقت ابكر اذا
اتخذت الحكومات خطوات تقدميه لرفع متوسط
الدخل ومستويات التعليم التوقعات الجديده
هي اخبار جيده للبيئه العالميه فبمجرد
التغلب على التضخم الديموغرافي يبدا الضغط
على الطبيعه والمناخ في التراجع وليس فقط
الطبيعه تبدا بالتراجع ايضا التوترات
الاجتماعيه والسيا المرتبطه
[موسيقى]
رسمت الدراسات السابقه صوره اكثر قتامه
للكثافه السكانيه في العام الماضي مثلا
قدرت الامم المتحده ان عدد سكان العالم
سيصل الى تسعه مليارات و700 مليون نسمه
بحلول منتصف القرن وسيستمر في الارتفاع
لعده عقود بعد ذلك لكن بحسب الدراسه
الجديده فانه في حاله العمل كالمعتاد
يتوقع ان تكون السياسات الحاليه كافيه
للحد من النمو السكاني العالمي الى اقل من
تسعه مليارات في عام 2046 ثم تنخفض الى
سبعه مليارات و300 مليون في عام 2100 في
السيناريو الثاني الاكثر تفائلا ومع قيام
الحكومات في جميع انحاء العالم برفع
الضرائب على الاثرياء للاستثمار في
التعليم والخدمات الاجتماعيه وتحسين
المساواه يقدر ان الاعداد البشريه يمكن ان
تصل الى ثمانيه مليارات ونصف المليار في
وقت مبكر من عام 2040 ثم بنحو عام واحد
الى حوالي سته مليارات في 2100 وفقا لهذه
الدراسه فانه بحلول عام 2050 تكون
انبعاثات غاز الاحتباس الحراري اقل بنسبه
90% تقريبا مما كانت عليه في عام 2020
وذلك بعد انخفاض اعداد السكان لكن
المؤلفين لهذه الدراسه يحضرون من ان يؤدي
انخفاض عدد السكان ايضا الى خلق مشاكل
جديده مثل تقليص القوى العامله زياده
الضغط على الرعايه الصحيه المرتبطه
بمجتمعات الشيخوخه كاليابان مثلا وكوريا
[موسيقى]
من عمان ينضم الينا رئيس اتحاد الجمعيات
البيئيه عمر شوشان سيد عمر اهلا بك معنا
في مساء العربيه رمضان كريم
اهلا وسهلا مساء الخير اهلا بك على عكس كل
التقارير التي رسمت صوره قاتمه عن الكثافه
السكانيه سابقا اليوم تقرير جديد يقول انه
الكثافه السكانيه ستصل الى ذروتها قريبا
ولكن تعود سريعا الى الانخفاض والتراجع
الى اي مدى هذا مهم بالنسبه للبيئه ماذا
يدعو للتفا
بكل تاكيد بان يعني مساله الزياده
الطبيعيه للسكان وايضا يعني زياده النمو
السكاني يشكل ضغط على الموارد البيئيه
والطبيعيه ويعني اي انخفاض في عدد السكان
سيعكس بشكل او باخر على يعني خفض
الاستهلاك
والانتاج
للموارد الطبيعيه ولكن يبقى تبقى المحابير
دائما هي حول طبيعه الاستهلاك حول كميات
الانتاج
ولذلك الامم المتحده دائما تدعو الى ما
يسمى بالانتاج المستدام والاستهلاك
المستدام فلذلك قد يكون هناك نعم انخفاض
في في عدد السكان ولكن قد تزيد من حاله
الاستهلاك كما نعيش في هذه الايام بما
يسمى بحاله الاستهلاك المفرط فلذلك حسب
تقديرات يعني مؤسسات مختصه
نقول بان يعني الان عدد سكان الكره
الارضيه تحتاج الى يعني كره ارضيه ونصف
حتى تتمكن من تلبيه احتياجاتهم للموارد
الطبيعيه لذلك حاله الاستهلاك المفرط هي
هي دائما يعني مؤشر قلق بالنسبه للبيئيين
في الحديث
هذا الكوكب ام هذه المساله تشمل كل
البلدان وكل الاقاليم وكل المناطق وهل هذا
يتعلق ليس فقط بان عدد السكان لن يكون
بتزايد اكثر فاكثر بل انه طبيعه الاستهلاك
لدى البشر الان اصبح لديها وعي اكثر مثلا
في الاهتمام بالبيئه والحفاظ على كوكبهم
[موسيقى]
يعني خلينا نكون اكثر واقعيه نعم في هناك
حديث كثير عن قضايا البيئه والتغير
المناخي ولكن لا ينعكس بشكل واضح على
الحاله الاستهلاكيه الحاله الاستهلاكيه في
ظل الثوره المعلوماتيه وايضا السوشيال
ميديا كما يسمى بالتسويق واسع المدى يعني
اصبح هناك في استهلاك كبير جدا وهذا يظهر
بشكل يعني واضح في كافه الاقاليم وخاصه
الدول يعني ذات الرفاه الاقتصادي الاكثر
التي تتمتع بقوه شرائيه بالمقابل هناك جزء
نتحدث عن دول القرن الافريقي وايضا نتحدث
عن دول الجنوب في الكره الارضيه يكون
استهلاك اقل نتيجه يعني عدم وجود قوى قوى
شرائيه لذلك
يعني في هناك معلومه جيده في هذا الاطار
بان العالم سكان الكره الارضيه يستهلكوا
موارد يعني المخصصه مثلا لنقول عام 2023
في شهر سبعه ينتهي الرصيد من الموارد
الطبيعيه ويبدا يعني
استغلال الارصده التي تكون الاجيال
اللاحقه فلذلك يعني للاسف
موارد او القدره الحيويه للكره الارضيه لا
تكفي للسكان سكان الكره الارضيه
بهذا الوقت تحديدا فلذلك يعني المساله
تحتاج الى وعي اكبر في موضوع ترشيد
الاستهلاك وايضا نتحدث عن ان لكل لكل يعني
السكان او لكل فرد على وجه هذه البسيطه
هناك ما يسمى بالبصمه الكربونيه والبصمه
المائيه بمعنى انه يعني يحتاج الى طاقه
اكثر يحتاج الى موارد مائيه ايضا غذائيه
فلذلك المساله يعني تحتاج الى دراسه ولست
متفائلا انا كمختص في الاشيان البيئي بهذه
الدراسه بشكل كما يعني يعني ظهرت حجم من
التفاؤل في هذه في هذا التقرير فلذلك
المساله تحتاج الى دراسه اكثر وايضا من
مؤسسات مختصه مثل مؤسسه المتحده للسكان
وهي المختصه في الدراسات السكانيه فلذلك
المساله بشكل او باخر ترتبط فقط في كميه
الاستهلاك للفرد من من الموارد الطبيعيه
وايضا البصمه الكربونيه التي يخلفها نتيجه
استهلاكه للطاقه بشكل بشكل واضح خاصه
الطاقه التي تاتي من مصادر الوقود
الاحفوري
على كل حال الله يديمه علينا
ان شاء الله هالكوكب بيكون مزيد ومزيد من
الناس ولكن نتحدث عن نوعيه وليس عدد شكرا
جزيلا
اتحاد الجمعيات البيئيه عمر شوشه